Hannah Brown is getting real about her
struggles post Bachelorette let's get
that straight
the former Miss Alabama took to
Instagram on Monday to get candid about
how her life has changed over the last
year and her battle to maintain her
identity she wrote in part quote I'm
struggling life is so different since
last August I've been in love with
multiple people I got engaged I broke
off an engagement and I shared it all
with millions of people I'm living on my
own for the first time and shuffling
through this life of next steps with
press media and opportunities galore
it's really hard to feel that way when
you have to compartmentalize
relationships the 24 year old continued
the lengthy post saying that she misses
her friends and family back in Alabama
who she says have watched her quote life
explode Hannah made sure to clarify that
she wasn't complaining but was
definitely reflecting I have so many
blessings to be thankful for
however it's uncharted territory for me
and it's been hard to really process
what the heck is going on
Hannah wrapped up her post explaining
quote life is beautiful but wild I think
it's okay to be strong to know you're
strong but to still feel weak
simultaneously I believe that's when the
magic happens just two weeks ago fans
watched Hannah's season finale of The
Bachelorette which featured her breakup
from fiance Jed Wyatt where does your
relationship stand now I am NOT with Jed
anymore and this moment when she boldly
asked out her runner-up Tyler Cameron I
just thought maybe we could go her dream
can just hang
I would love to just tell me what not
that well they got that drink a few days
later and he spent the night at her
place in LA we definitely hung out and
talked about everything I know nobody
will believe me just hanging out and
actually talking it was good to be able
to catch up we have a lot to talk if we
had a lot to talk about but two days
later he was spotted on multiple dates
with Gigi Hadid is this legit is it is
it confirmed I'm good on Tyler I saw
feelings but I'm also single and he's
single and I want to keep my options
open and he can keep his options open
since then Hannah posted about letting
go on social media which naturally fans
speculate was in reference to Tyler but
he's like dating Gigi Hadid and my whole
mind is blown
he recently caught up with former
bachelorette Jojo Fletcher and her
fiance Jordan Rogers and they weighed in
on Tyler's outings with Gigi day long
ready to mingle
what I feel would i if I was Hanna would
I feel great absolutely no I would feel
really crappy and the fact that a
student had be it I mean good for him
though they're all see yeah but also
just remember oh I feel like he should
just do what he wants it makes him happy
she should do what she wants me they're
both single my heart gets broken through
all this because of just learning and
growing and putting my heart out there
the way that I did I feel for Hanna and
I love how honest she's being along the
way we see you and we love you girl of
course I will be here to keep you
up-to-date on all the latest
bachelor/bachelorette news so make sure
to keep it locked right here on ET until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now